[Music]
the best way i can describe this thing
is it's like harlem globetrotters but
for baseball and so the story behind
this is basically um
so there's this guy named jesse cole and
he was an amateur baseball player and he
got hurt and he was like well what the
heck what am i going to do now and
there's i actually don't know which
league this is but it's a minor league
baseball league it's called i think it's
called the coastal plains league is that
what it is that's right
and i i actually don't know entirely
what that is i guess is it like a minor
minor league or a proper minor league
i don't know i don't know
so but anyway so it has quote
professional baseball players but i
don't think they make a lot of money and
he bought this team and by bought
savannah georgia had a has a minor
league team and it wasn't doing so well
and they're like jesse do you just want
this just like figure out how to make it
work and we'll just pay you or you could
just you know pay us back when he starts
making a little bit of money
all right so um anyway uh so they
savannah georgia they had a minor league
baseball team they gave it to this guy
jesse cole he bought it but it was like
so little money that he like
overdrafted his bank account which for
by like a couple thousand dollars so he
didn't have any startup money his wife
helped him do it and then
the team said like you know he's like
how many great how many people like come
to uh come to the games they're like i
don't know like 100 or 200 sometimes
it's picking up and he's like oh
what did i get myself into yeah and they
give him this stadium and it's
completely empty and he's like what do i
do with the stadium how do i get people
to come he didn't know anything and so
he goes you know what screw it we're
gonna make this one thing we're gonna do
one thing which is make baseball fun
and he has like this naming ceremony and
they're like well what are you gonna
name it like the savannah like you know
trojans or something and he's like no no
no
everyone this is i want to introduce you
guys to the savannah bananas and it's
like a hilarious uh mascot of just a
banana and they're like wait what's
going on he's like no no so what we're
gonna do is we're gonna have fun and so
what they do basically is they have
normal games in the league where they
actually are like trying to win and like
doing real stuff but at the league even
at those games what they do is like the
players will introduce themselves or
like the umpire and there's like crazy
videos on tick tock the umpire when he
goes down to sweep the
uh batter's box he like drops down low
and they play like get low by little
john and it's just like hilarious they
have male cheerleaders they do like
trick plays they have like choreographed
dances that the players do in between
innings they have like um instead of
like a like a hot like hot dance team
they have like a grandmother's dance
team so all the the dancers are really
old and move really slow and stuff like
that and then even other things at the
game so he he said he goes but i got
this team and he's just a baseball
player right he's like
he goes i just realized like um
i don't know anything about how i'm
gonna like make this work but i just put
it all on the line like they basically
sold their home overdrafted their
accounts and like they went all in on
this
and he's like so i read every walt
disney book and pt barnum book for
inspiration and i realized it's not
about baseball it's about entertainment
and he's like so i'm gonna yeah like
we're we're not here to be the most
winningest minor league baseball team
we're here to have the most fun and
create the most fun environment that
people are going to want to feel like
they belong to so he's like you know
what are the things i hate about a
baseball game i'm gonna do the exact
opposite oh i hate that there's just ads
everywhere in the stadium okay i'm gonna
rip all those down and we're gonna put
funny things up instead because i hate
um that like you know just buying like a
beer is like 14 you just feel like
you're getting gouged so they switch
their ticket prices to be all-inclusive
so you buy ticket unlimited you know
food and drink or whatever it is i don't
know how they do that with alcohol but
like
that's what he says all inclusive
tickets and then they you know instead
of
you know a baseball's really slow so
they're like it's a two-hour like limit
basically to these games and like
there's no like we don't walk up to the
mound and talk to the pitcher for like
five minutes uh there's no bunts there's
no and they did all these things to
speed up the game and make it more fun
and entertaining and then they also have
like the normal game so they play in the
league and coincidentally in that league
you know they won the championship so
they went from actually being the worst
team to the most winning team
ted lasso yeah so it worked but
then they do this other thing called
banana ball so like in between the
normal games they like continue hiring
the team throughout the offseason and
they travel from city to city and they
also host this at their own league or at
their own stadium and they have this
thing called banana ball which means
there's no buns no visits to the mound a
two-hour limit if someone in the stands
catches a foul ball the batter is still
out
well there's like a video that's like
someone comes to bat they're on stilts
yeah and then they throw out the first
some kid comes out and throws a
banana
right like everything is gimmicked and
their social media uh by the way they
have four thousand people that comes to
every game look at the tick tocks that i
posted up there did you watch them
they're hilarious i've been seeing these
over the like last year or so like the
the pitcher does like a funny dance
basically before he throws the pitch and
it's just like it's just so likeable
like that's the best way i could
describe it is it's so
likeable you you see it you're like i
wanna i wish i was there i wish i was
having as much fun as those guys are
having and um and like i love that they
don't take this too seriously and boring
the way that it's so counter to
everything everything else you'll see in
sports yeah it doesn't like the bar the
discipline bar isn't exactly like really
high you know like with wrestling you
have to diet and like take it seriously
with baseball not really as much and so
this team it's hilarious and i think
it's a good business i read somewhere it
was doing like six or seven million in
sales but
i could actually see this becoming i
don't know if it's never gonna be like
huge huge like multi-billion but i think
this would be a sick thing to own
[Music]
you